picadas y protestas por tercera noche
consecutiva en varias ciudades de españa
tras la condena y encarcelamiento del
rapero pablo hasél por enaltecimiento al
terrorismo a través de twitter y por
amenazas su detención causó la
indignación de miles de ciudadanos que
alegaron falta de libertad de expresión
con protestas que terminaron en choques
violentos con la policía y que han
provocado el arresto de decenas de
personas en todo el país el suceso fue
el detonante que desencadenó la ira de
los jóvenes españoles con la tasa de
desempleo más alta de europa y no sólo
por el tema de que hay presos políticos
sino porque nos enfrentamos a una crisis
económica súper grande los jóvenes
estamos muy precarizado
tenemos las tasas de desempleo en las
que somos los primeros en europa y lo
dejas él ha sido un detonante
los mayores altercados fueron
registrados en barcelona donde una
ciudadana perdió un ojo a causa de un
disparo con una bala de goma el martes
por lo que se ha abierto una
investigación la tensión parece estar
escalando también en la esfera política
mientras el partido socialista guarda
silencio
socio de gobierno podemos se posicionó
el jueves a favor del indulto de castle
y pidió también el de otro rapero
exiliado
el indulto no solo lo hemos pedido para
hacer en coordinación con su abogado
diego el orden lo hemos hecho extensible
aval tonic en coordinación con su
abogado gonzalo boyé merecemos una
democracia sin raperos en prisión ni en
el exilio esto podría fracturar la
coalición de gobierno en españa entre el
partido socialista y podemos mientras el
país sigue sumido en manifestaciones